l'offre de agir participation qui
aujourd'hui la seule offre globale
disons le nom qui reprendrait l'ensemble
des activités du groupe france antilles
dont des différents journaux sur la
guadeloupe sur la guyane la martinique
et les différentes radios
il y avait effectivement une casse
sociale importante puisque 111 salariés
seraient laissés sur le carreau
outre les 111 salariés laissés sur le
carreau de nombreuses interrogations
demeurent sur le plan social pour les
salariés qui seraient repris il perdrait
énormément sur le plan social des
intérêts des interrogations collective
sur la convention collective qui sera
applicable demeurent les réponses n'ont
pas été portées aujourd'hui malgré les
questions que nous avons formulées à
l'avocat d'agir participation nous avons
bien senti que certaines questions
agaçait mais sans pour autant nécessaire
compte tenu de la circonstance
particulière que vous avez évoquées qui
le fait que agir participation est
d'ores et déjà l'actionnaire majoritaire
dont ceux de la cei france antilles etc
en fait une dans une situation
particulière qui nécessite
l'autorisation du procureur de la
république pour que agir participation
soit le repreneur
ce qui soulève davantage de questions
alors le avantle alors l'avis des
représentants du salarié sur sept ce
projet social et ses conséquences et
bien évidemment défavorable mais ils
sont malheureusement dos au mur dans le
sens où agir participation à ce que nous
évoquions fait en sorte qu'il ne puisse
y avoir d'autres offres si vous voulez
globale qui soit valable qui puisse être
sérieuse présenter et donc c'est
malheureusement une situation d'impasse
pour les salariés est ce que nous
essayons de négocier aujourd'hui ce que
nous voulons obtenir c'est que des
garanties complémentaires soit accordée
sur le plan social c'est que agir
participation dont l'avocat nous a
indiqué croire en sa solidité financière
fasse un effort notamment en abondant au
plan de sauvegarde de l'emploi pour
permettre à ceux qui partiraient à ceux
qui vont partir en nécessairement de
retrouver plus facilement un travail
d'avoir une
un avenir plus serein